[Music]
hello, how are you, sal y jaramillo greets you
with your brief informative today, Tuesday
, December 1,
the fire that claimed the lives of
businessman jon and kate, who died after
injuries sustained in mid-
November in an accident inside a
housing in the canary islands that according to
iteam investigators the house in
which he was staying belonged to a
sapos employee, it is unknown how
the incident started and how he
was trapped despite the fact that everyone
in the house managed to
escape  As firefighters entered and
pulled Say unconscious, he was
hospitalized for nearly two weeks before
passing away. Chay was 46 years old
upon news of his death.
Las Vegas residents have come out to honor
Chauncey and his efforts to boost
the city's economy.  especially the one in
downtown las vegas a petition is
circulating on the internet to rename
part of 6th street north of freeman
with the name of d  e jonnie safeway the
signatures have been accumulating on the
bug page and there are already 25,000
signatures that they set as their goal
the mayor of the city carmen
told
disney that she believes that her legacy should be
commemorated in some way, so
the  The issue will be addressed at the
municipal meeting today and today is
World AIDS Day and global solidarity
seeks to raise awareness in the world about the
disease and also to remember and support
people living with HIV as well as
people who have been
impacted and  those who have died from the
virus today the nara state and
fridzon organization and several local casinos will
commemorate this day by lighting up their
buildings as well as their screens and
banners outside their
properties in red
color lighting is scheduled for
8 o'clock  night and we will be
broadcasting live on our internet pages
and social networks
now we will pass with your weather forecast
we will start the month of December
s  in the rain it will be a sunny week with
temperatures around 66 degrees and a
low of 39 degrees today have a
good day I am salt and jaramillo and this
was the Spanish edition
[Music]
yes